[Music]
as a man were you happy to see that been
asked like apologize to your wife sure
yeah of course
I don't want to make a big deal of it
because she didn't but yeah I think
everything that's come out in the last
couple weeks starting with the Harvey
Weinstein I think I think all anybody
who has talked about it and even those
that haven't yet are incredibly brave
and I think it's it's time for change
and I hope hopefully that this hopefully
all this stuff is gonna change this
business a but it's it's all over it's
prevalent all over and I'm proud of all
these women and then my wife she to me
is the most amazing person I've ever met
there's no one stronger than her how she
is able to balance all the things that
she balances and be a strong voice for
good is is amazing and I just I couldn't
be more proud every single day as she
does something that just amazes me I she
has made me such a better person so I'm
a lucky dude I love your your marriage
and everything congratulations you and
Hillary baby number two yeah baby number
two are you guys expecting are you
preparing yeah we probably should be
preparing more but I'm still working
unfortunately I know we're very excited
I got to go home for two days earlier
this week but we're excited I don't know
where else to put it I mean a little
baby girl so the family grows we're
pumps it's pretty cool and Gus is
excited so we're it's going to be fun
you
[Music]